is your mark. As you can see, it's split up into two parts. We have our accuracy and our
presentation on this side. So we'll start off with the accuracy first. So your accuracy is
actually scored from a 4. So from the number 4, you're actually marked during your presentation
of your pattern. And then with that one, any mistakes that you make, whether if it's a minor
mistake, you get a minus of 0.1. If it's a major mistake, you get minus 0.3. So I'll just let you
guys know about the difference between the two. So with a minor mistake, it's a very, very small
thing. So say we're doing an outer block. If it's not your shoulder height, maybe it's a little bit
lower, or maybe it's a tiny bit higher, that's a minor mistake. So that's a 0.1. A major mistake
would be, you're supposed to do an outer block in the pattern. So you're supposed to do an outer
block in the pattern, but you forget and you say you do a rich hand strike instead. So that would
be a major mistake. So with a minor mistake, let's say pattern 1, for example, there's 20 steps.
It's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14, 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns, sorry, the 20 steps.
So the reason for that one being, it needs to be absolutely perfect to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So it's not uncommon, let's say there's 20 steps, and you made, let's say 15 mistakes. So what would
that be? So we'll leave that there on this side, and we'll come back and we'll just calculate the
score at the end. So a major mistake, say you're supposed to turn to the left, but you turn to the
right, that would be a major mistake. So obviously, we do want to try to avoid any of these major
mistakes. So after we've done our pattern, that's when we move on to the pattern. So we're going to
the presentation side. So the presentation, as you can see, it's from a score of 6. This 6 is
actually split up into three parts. So we have 1, 2, 3 here. So with this one, for a score of 2 is
your power and speed. Your rhythm is also a score of 2, and your expression of energy is also scored
out of 2 as well. So we'll start off with the power and speed. So with this one, whether it's your
blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything, it's all about the power and speed.
Anything that you do, you need to be nice and strong, and it has to be fast as well. So it's one
thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch, but it has to be both strong and fast to
get high in that category. The next part is your rhythm. So the rhythm, when you do start your
pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern. It's not just really fast all the way through. It's
not slow all the way through. There's a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect to what it's
doing as well. So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm, and that's also scored out of 2.
The last bit is your expression of energy. So what is expression of energy? So that's basically
how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well. So let's say
you're doing your pattern really well. It's really fast and it's strong. Your rhythm is really great,
but you're not shouting very loud. Or you can kind of tell, the judges can kind of tell you're not
shouting very loud, but you're a little bit nervous. So that's what we need to kind of improve
on as well. So I'll just come on out to this side. So with this one, for color belts and black belts,
it's actually scored a little bit differently. So if you're a color belt, you'll actually,
your average, so where the judges actually mark you from, it's actually from a 1.1. So this is
your average. So say you did, you did all right, you did average compared to everyone else,
your score for one, two, and three, it'll start from a 1.1. So if you're less than average in the
judges' eyes, you might go down to, say for your power and speed, you might get a one or even a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4. So each individual category,
you need to obviously get as high as you can. If you're a black belt, generally,
depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.1.
So 1.3 would be your average that you start from. So say your power and speed
was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now. Say your rhythm was only about average,
it wasn't amazing, it might be just a 1.3. But let's say you didn't shout very loud,
so your expression of energy, your average was 1.3, it might drop to say, let's say,
1.0. So with this one, we'll come over down to this side. So with this one, as I was saying,
it's a total of 10. So let's see. For presentation, we had 0.7, 1, 2, 3. So you had a 3.7.
Let's say you made 15 mistakes. So with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged if you do get
pretty high in your mistakes. With the judges, we have three judges usually at the panel,
and each judge, obviously, is very subjective. So from their point of view, you might have made
a lot of mistakes, or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well. So that's why we have
three judges, and we average it out as well. Okay, so say we did our 15 mistakes, very small
mistakes. So if they're all...
Well, minus 0.1 would be 1.5. So you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5. So this would be your
accuracy score. So with our presentation like before, we're saying we've got a 3.7 here. So
we add these numbers after the judges are finished scoring. So you would get, for this pattern, a 6.2,
which is actually very good. So I'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number
here. So if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above, and you do your patterns, it's
not uncommon. Generally, for a color belt, the average is about a 4 to 5. So if you get a number
between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern, that's actually generally considered pretty good. So
anything above that, you can consider yourself pretty good. If you're a black belt, the average
would say, because we're talking here about the higher presentation as an average, anything from
5 to 6 is actually considered pretty good. And anything over a 7 is actually considered almost
world-class. So if you get a 7 for any of your patterns, you generally need to pattern it in a
4 Xe style. So even if you're a black belt, if you're a black belt, you really need to go pick
up on this number. This number means that whatever the color you're going with, do not go through 5
Xe style, even if it's a black belt, it's going to be a 6.0. So that's something we're going to talk
about a little bit more now. So just remember this number is going to be the number to go.
So if you're a white belt, you're going to say 4, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13 then that's another number.
So this is a full scale number. So it's going to be anything but this number. Otherwise now you're
going to be talking about a 6.2.
Well, I'm not playing with numbers here. You're just playing with numbers. So here's what happens.
Another judge on the other side, maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did, so
maybe this one would be a little bit lower, it might be a five point something.
Another judge on the other side, they scored a little bit higher, so we'd get the three
numbers, and then we'd average that as well.
So, I hope this helped you guys, so make sure you enjoy your Pumzang competitions, and any
time, make sure, obviously, you record down your numbers as well, so it's very important
to keep track of your numbers.
We're going to rate your performance, and Barton, rate your performance.
So, this is minor errors, you can, real time, real time, you cannot pause this time, it's
like a real judge to yourself, and then major errors, while you're watching the video, and
then after the performance.
So, it's power and speed, coordination, rhythm, and expression for energy images.
Alright, thank you so much.
I might have to pause it, is there one?
No, no, pause.
Yeah, it's like a real competition.
So, please go ahead and pause this time, and listen for ISSSEC and have a little check
and answer that, and make sure you read the math looks like what we have and where it
is going, and it's showing popped up in that pop-up, so please enjoy your Pumzang as you
enjoy your trends.
And now, Pumzang again!
All aboard, eine, zwei, três, vier, fünf.
Go on.
All right.
Okay.